no one knows what the future holds like
tomorrow like
i couldn't tell you
what's going to happen i mean i'm here
my locker is right next side to
you know one of the men who means the
most to me in the world and
i think about just being able to come to
work and see him every single day and
how special
this could be so i couldn't sit here and
tell you
whether i'm going to be here
want to be here don't want to be here
this is exactly where i'm at now
and i wouldn't rather be anywhere else
you know so
it's something that
like i said god has a plan and and in
the offseason everything will figure
itself out
i don't know beckham jr talking about
his future with the browns yesterday in
big cat i mean this does not sound like
a guy who is committed to staying in
cleveland he was talking about jarvis
landry close friend of his that was one
of the attractions for beckham to come
to cleveland but what gets him to stay
there you know based on things he said
earlier this year i think he'd love to
play for the patriots or a team that
operates like the patriots and i think
he's been in cleveland long enough to
know that under freddie kitchens that is
not going to happen and i just really
wonder what beckham wants
uh he doesn't seem to be all in maybe he
wants to see who the coach is going to
be maybe he wants to see what other
moves are going to be made maybe he
wants to see whether or not they're
going to offer him a new contract but it
sure seems like he is very
ambiguous and non-committal about
whether or not he even wants to be in
cleveland next year
all right let me throw this out there
mike
if you're the browns do you want no
doubt beckham in cleveland next year
well i don't well here's the thing i
mean jarvis landry's had better stats
this year but when you have a guy in
odell beckham jr who is constantly
receiving extra attention and double
coverage
uh that's helpful the problem is it's
created extra stress and strain for
baker mayfield and i think one of the
reasons mayfield's regressed is because
he feels compelled to look at odell
beckham jr maybe a little bit longer
than he should it screws up his reads
and you know you you want the
quarterback to just throw to whoever's
open you don't want him to feel like he
has to get the ball to odell beckham jr
if he doesn't then that's going to be an
issue that doesn't work so you know may
hey look at the bra if the browns can
get
what they put in by way of draft picks
or close to it i think it makes sense to
consider moving on but you got to act
like you want to keep him or you're
never going to get maximum value for him
in trade like the steelers last year got
almost peanuts for antonio brown because
everybody knew they didn't want to keep
him the browns have to act like they
want him
and this isn't me going at odell beckham
because he's an all-world talent but one
of the issues the browns have had this
year is noise and having the outside
noise and odell beckham has not had any
real you know odell beckham i'm going to
fight something on the sideline moments
but still odell beckham comes with noise
whether you like it or not so i think
maybe if this your john dorsey you're
like we got to minimize the noise we got
to make this baker's team and just go
with that
and whoever the coach is is going to be
making that decision as well and it may
not be freddy kitchens odo beckham jr
pushing back against those who
interpreted his comments yesterday as an
indication he's not happy with the
browns he tweeted just within the last
half hour i never said i was not happy
in cleveland just like everyone else i'm
hoping for better results period next
story please nobody said that he said
he's not happy in cleveland but he never
committed to staying in cleveland he's
left the door open
and you can't get
i don't know if it's a maturity thing i
don't know if he's doing on purpose if
he just speaks he doesn't realize that
those words don't disappear into the
ether that people are going to actually
pay attention what he says i really do
think that's a big part of it i don't
think he has yet figured out
that when you say something and you have
a name like otto beckham jr people are
actually going to listen to your words
and possibly interpret them and try to
find the meaning
even if you don't think it means
anything
uh first of all thank you for watching
odell hello hopefully your morning's
going well uh
i mean we were i think the tweet came
right after we were talking about it but
yeah
this is a classic case of the more you
talk the more it's it's it is
a snowball that starts when a guy says
something in the media the media
responds then he says well you took
everything out of context and the media
responds you know what the best way to
do it it's to not talk to the media and
win football games that's kind of the
tried and true method here if you want
to talk about not having any
distractions
well and i think the key is getting
proper training on how to handle those
types of questions it can't just be your
inner monologue that gets laid out for
the world to hear because they are going
to hear it they are going to pay
attention to it and we're all going to
interpret it however we can and i
interpreted his comments from yesterday
not as he's not happy now
but that the jury's out on whether or
not he's gonna be back next year and
based on what i heard from him yesterday
i don't think he's going to be back next
year so yeah uh
you know and and so he just
that's why it works for bill belichick
we hate it
but he never says anything that anyone
can use against him
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports